and federal numbers show one person dies
every 45 minutes from a DUI nationally
but those lives lost here in the valley
are being remembered while bringing
awareness to the problem a miles
L'Oreal is in the works along Kyle
Canyon Road which is in route to Mount
Charleston Ryan Matthey joining us now
live in studio tonight with what it
means to the victim's families yeah
Denise and Brian while police continue
to push drunk driving prevention more
lives are lost and while no one has the
exact answers on how to stop these
drivers from getting behind the wheel
victims families are hoping a miles long
Memorial will help reverse the problem
from then to now has it gotten any
easier
no
no it doesn't Diane Malone still Grieves
over four years later her daughter then
33 year old Krista Malone Puente and her
husband 39 year old damaso Puente taken
away by a drunk driver my daughter and
her husband were just sitting at a
stoplight waiting for the light to
change
when he rammed him at over 100 miles an
hour
they had no chance he didn't give him a
chance a horrific accident killing the
couple instantly a part of me died
that day with her
she is literally a part of me
and I can't get that back
a scene all too common in the Valley
Metro Police reports nearly 30 DUI
fatalities this year just in their
jurisdiction lost lives not forgotten
here along State Route 157 at Kyle
Canyon local non-profit stop DUI will
soon Place nearly 15 miles of signs as
part of their annual DUI victim Memorial
the names of victims meant to bring
awareness to the problem in hopes to end
it the Malone Puentes names will be
there I want them to realize how many
people have suffered the ultimate loss
and I want them to realize that it could
happen to them
now stop DUI does this Memorial at no
cost to the families the deadline to
submit a victim's name is this Saturday
and those interested can find out how on
our website the signs will be put up
later this fall reporting live in studio
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now